titan trying to clean up a big mess
after the white house said he was
working with facebook to censor
americans the president even claimed
facebook had blood on its hands but
now after the backlash biden's trying to
walk it back
the only pandemic we have is among the
unvaccinated
i was asked that question about what do
i think is happening
facebook isn't killing people these 12
people are out there giving
misinformation anyone listening to it is
getting hurt by it
it's killing people it's bad information
my hope is that facebook instead of
taking it personally that somehow i'm
saying facebook is killing people
that they would do something about the
misinformation
uh does that spin past the smell test
no i love how facebook now is like
they're just mad because they missed
their vaccine target so they're gonna
blame us so does now facebook understand
what it's dealing with
biden company and all the liberal
lemmings they are neither your friend
nor your ally they want to control you
and
they will if you don't get on board what
they're doing they will call you
a murderer in essence i know that biden
walked that back but
this is essentially what jinsaki said
last week oh if you're bothered by the
white house
uh trampling on the constitution the
first amendment censoring
speech online government overreach well
then somehow
you want people to die from covet but
that's that
that's the choice and it's it's
threatening language it's
you know they're trying they're doing
what all fascists do as carol markowitz
would say every fascist always has a
great reason why they want to shut down
information and speech it's always for
your own
good uh i will add one uh one last thing
anybody who wants to talk about the
vaccine blame game let's start with
kamla harris
and her fear-mongering about the vaccine
in the kind of
anti-the kind of anti-vac science denier
last year talking about the trump
vaccine joe biden did it andy cuomo did
it so if they're talking about people
not getting vaccinated it is on
the biden administration's shoulders
because it started last year
richard you're someone that values
liberty right so
are you concerned that the white house
is coordinated with a
private company a publicly traded i i
could
i'll be real on this one i could care
less about
whether they're talking to facebook or
asking them to do this or do that
because for me i think it's about
american lives
i think what we know is this right now
covid through this delta variant is on
the spread and like you guys said this
morning ainsley on the show you steve
and brian talked about if you have a
chance to get this vaccine please get
this vaccine because i don't want to see
another american lose their life
whether it be because of misinformation
whether it be because you hate the
democrats whether because you hate me
because i'm a democrat whether because
you don't like your doctor it really
doesn't matter
the information is out there go to the
cdc website read up on it
please get the vaccine so you can save
your life you could save your family's
life because i don't want to see another
american
lose their life when they have a chance
to get this vaccine
and be saved period actually you
followed it up by
saying also on the show it's your choice
right
so and that's we can dive into what
facebook is saying
let's be honest we all have the
information now we know
we should wear a mask if you if you feel
safer that way we know about social
distancing we know that there are three
vaccines that are readily available for
all of us
we have the information in front of us
now it's up to you to decide i'm okay
with facebook putting everything on
there and then i can
flip through all the research i can
print out the articles and i can make a
decision that's best for my family
i can sit down with my doctor what was
best for me was to get the vaccine
i don't know if it's offered to my
daughter i'll have to have conversations
with her doctor whether or not that's
going to be best for her and what that
means for her down the road
but i get to make that decision and
that's what is great about america
they're giving us the information and
listen there's the lady who's pregnant
who says i'm going to wait till after
the baby's born because i'm worried
there's the lady that has that rare
disease and her doctor said you are not
getting this
and that's their decision so i think we
have all the information now everyone
needs to take a step back
realize this is serious talk to your
doctor and make your own choice
greg this is rooted in laziness instead
of doing the work to convince the
population
and given the information that they need
they want to force it down your throat
yeah i mean i i disagree completely with
richard on this it has nothing to do
with information
it has to do with a violation of the
first amendment with the government is
pressuring the spigots of information
that is a violation of the first
amendment it doesn't matter if it's for
wrong information
we're not all going to be right 100 like
if you're expecting
100 right information it's never going
to happen
this is for wrong information the people
and you can't expect the people who
pushed
a four-year collusion lie to have any
authority
authority on information much well
they're an authority on misinformation
but that's that label is also nonsense
because it's designed to remove you from
a conversation
and it's being wielded by the last
people on earth
you should trust social media giants and
and the media and the government in
general
they they believe you have blood on your
hands
over misinformation but do not even talk
about murder look they don't talk about
crime rates but they talk about
whether or not your aunt you know
sent a meme that was critical of fouchy
to be fair i mean every amendment every
the whole constitution has limits and
one of the limits on the personnel is
you can't walk into a movie theater you
know that
and you'll fire but wait a minute but
wait a minute but wait a minute
i'm going to make my point but if you're
good if you're saying but if you're
saying that the vaccine gives you covid
that's the same thing that's so
justifiable we're going to finish this
up in a commercial
coming up can you say one thing please
for the love of god
we 30 of migrants won't take the vaccine
did they get it from facebook there's an
insidious
motive by this biden administration two
nfl teams didn't hit the 50
vaccination mark did they get it from 12
people on facebook
hell no they didn't and that would be
the last word coming up i'm steve ducey
i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page to catch
our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis